hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the prestigious mr dodge
invitational 2.0 it's anishkiri versus
jose fernando cuenca jimenez better
known as pepe
and it's uh it's a really wonderful game
that features uh well
a wonderful ending position that uh when
i learned about it i was very happy with
myself so
uh maybe uh you guys can also experience
that
if you don't know about what i'm talking
about about what i'm talking about
uh but yeah uh we're gonna get to that
so without further ado uh giri with the
white pieces opens
with d4 and it's a very long uh
theoretical
uh struggle uh but we will get to the
good stuff don't worry so d for d6 we
have knight to f3
knight to f6 and now c4 we have g6 going
for the king's indian setup
uh knights to c3 and the bishop to g7
so the king's indian defense is on the
board we have e4 striking in the center
and
uh castles here we have bishop to e2 and
the bishop to g4 so this is all very
standard
stuff i played many many times bishop to
e3
knight after d7 and now comes uh castles
by anish we have knight to c6
and now d5 striking in the center and
now knight to a5
although looking uh like a weird move it
is the way to go you you can't really go
for something like knight to e5
uh because uh well it's just not
not a great move so here uh what instead
of moving the knights to a5
uh first you eliminate the bishop uh so
you get rid of one of the defenders of
the e5 square and then you bring it to
a5 so again
if you go here then just bishop e2
guards the c4 pawn
and f4 is coming there's not much you
can do about this you'd have to free up
this square for this knight
and then for example captures captures
f4 goes back and this is just uh
well a brutal position to handle with
black
so of course black will not go for this
knight to a5 this is all standard theory
uh and the bishop back to e2 now
guarding the c4 pawn we have bishop
captures on c3
uh maybe an odd looking move giving up
your dark square bishop like this
but uh you know this has been tested by
our good friends the engines
uh so be captures and now e5
so closing closing the position here and
now asking do you want to capture alpha
or maybe do do you want to try something
else as probably
later on i'm gonna you know develop the
queen play some like f6 maybe double up
the rooks and the file then in the
future maybe push the pawn all the way
to f5
uh who knows what might happen here so
anish captures on e6
alpha and now f captures on e6 and
queen to d2 uh this position has been
reached before and
there are moves that were played here f4
is a very popular move here
but queen d2 the move on each place is a
new move so already as of
move 14 we have a completely new game so
let's see
how pepe deals with this pepe goes b6
and that's a
reasonable way to play you want to bring
the knight back to b7 then to c5 and
on c5 it's going to be an excellent
piece that's a great outpost why it
doesn't have a b-pawn or a d-pawn to
kick it away
and uh well that's uh well that's a very
nice plan and also black has a very nice
center here so here
f4 by anish and queen to e7 uh
developing the queen connecting the
rooks
rook eight to e1 and now knight to b7
continuing with the plan we have queen
to c2
and knight b to c5 now we have rook to
f2
now uh the the rooks are coming to the f
file so maybe in the future you can look
into something maybe like f5
rook to f7 black does the same rook e to
f1 and now
rook a to f8 so both players double up
on the f file
and now g3 strengthening the position
here a little bit
uh and here uh black needs to decide
what to do does he just want to you know
keep the keep the tension does he want
to you know maybe play queen f6 rook f6
maybe king h8
does he want to wait for white to make a
move or he does he want to play an
active move and here pepe goes
e5 so he wants to play an active move
and he does
we have f5 by anisha going for a nice
trick here
yeah and now g5 of course you don't want
to allow uh
opening of the position so g5 and now uh
g replace
g uh f6 and this is a pretty fun move
it's not a not maybe the most precise
move but
it is it is a great one because these
are blitz games five plus
zero so no increment games and you have
to always look for
uh uh you know ideas like this uh a nice
move here would have been h4
and now you're really threatening h
captures and g5 and if one captures then
g4 g5 and this will now be very strong
for white
however after this f6 move uh it's a
really crazy position
uh white sacrifices upon for the moment
uh
bishop captures and g5 and now i say
white sacrifices upon because black
should
definitely capture on e4 uh but if you
don't um
have a lot of time on the clock and if
you if you're not sure about what's
happening maybe this is a
uh maybe a too greedy of a phone grab
but uh
here white really doesn't have anything
better than capturing here because the
bishop and rook are under attack
here you just have to trade captures
captures and enjoy this position being
up upon with a better pawn structure
however uh in the game
queen the e6 was played and now anish
just plays
bishop captures rook captures and rook
f5 hoping for captures and captures then
he will get a nice pass pawn here
but again capturing an e4 is uh is
mandatory here because now you're again
uh elim
you've eliminated the defender of the
rook here you're attack you're attacking
it three times
and there's just nothing better for
white than to trade captures captures
and again
you enjoy this position being uh being
up a pawn
but instead rook captures an f5 was
played e
captures and now queen to h6 like i said
these are blitz games no seconds
increment uh so
uh you have to be very quick we have
king to g2
and queen to e3 now we have rook to f3
anisha kicks away the queen and queen e4
now pinning the rook and also offering a
queen trade
and now we go into this end game that we
were going
uh going for the the entire game
uh queen captures knight capture so we
have g for now anish now preparing h4
and g5
so king g7 we have to get ready for that
h4 and now
h6 stopping g5 so bishop d3 attacking
the knight on knight c5 attacking the
bishop and now
bishop to c2 and here the bishop and the
knight are nicely controlling each other
as you see so king to f6 against
stopping g5 and
rook g3 anish wants to execute g5 here
so rook g8
stopping g5 and now king to f3
and now again it's a pretty pretty
drawish position there is not much for
either side to do you can never execute
g5
black is controlling it three times and
other than that you really don't have a
way of entering this game
so uh here black can uh just to go for a
drop he can just repeat moves knight b7
knight t5 knight b7 knight t5 and there
is nothing white can white can do about
this
uh but it's uh you know uh easier said
than done
when when it's a blitz game with with no
seconds on the clock so here
c6 preparing to strike in the center
with d5
and now bishop to e4 this is how anish
looks for chances he goes for the
c6 pawn and now basically forces knight
captures on e4 so here pepe goes for it
we have captures captures and
now uh d5 with check and this is a great
pawn sacrifice
as it's a temporary one and you will win
the f5 pawn
and this is how he does it we have
captures captures and captures
and now of course h5 uh the pawn cannot
be captured the rook on g3 would be
hanging
so g5 with check and now king captures
an f5 and now both of them have a nice
pass pawn and they
of course need to start pushing them so
here g6
uh and now uh you have to first play
rook to d8
check however here e4 was played and uh
although
giri did not take advantage of this you
can actually win this pawn just rook g5
check king moves and you pick up the
pawn or if you go for something like
this then
rook king f4 and now it's winning but
that's uh
besides the point i'm only showing you
guys this uh so
uh you know what's happening but for
for them to see it in uh blizz game with
few seconds on the clock it's very very
unrealistic
so here e3 king f7 and that's it white
wins if
if e2 just you know trying to promote
the queen rook g1 we guard the d1 square
and once this rook moves wherever then
we're going to play g7 g8 and then win
the game but it's also
very similar to what happened in the
game anish played
g7 uh we have king to f4 and this is uh
black's
last well playable position because here
e3 was mandatory but here he played king
to f4
and now rook to g1 and we basically end
up with the same position that we've
already shown
uh e3 king to e6 now comes king f7
sorry e2 king f7 attacking the rook now
rook the c8
uh and now just bringing a queen into
the game so captures captures and now of
course uh
we have to do something about this pawn
but uh it's impossible to capture it
black will promote this pawn so we just
have to play the king and pawn in game
two to
win so here king g7 king f2 we moved the
rook rook the b1 was played and now
black also brings the queen into the
game so captures captures
and after all of that madness we have a
king component game where it's king and
three points against king and three
pawns but
white is completely winning problem is
white can eliminate this pawn and start
pushing this pawn whereas black has to
eliminate
both of these pawns to at least try and
get the b pawn through
but uh that's all you know all part of
chess king g6 king d2 and now
king captures on h5 with uh king
captures on c3
uh king to g6 now there are only four
more
moves for anish to bring the queen into
the game and the black requires a few
more
so here b5 h5 we have b4
h6 and now king to b2 you have to
eliminate the a2 pawn as well
h7 and now king captures on a2 we have
h8 with queen and now b3 and now we've
reached the position from the thumbnail
and this is what i wanted to show you
guys that
uh now you might be thinking okay you
have a few seconds on the clock what
what do i play this how do i stop the
pawn
uh maybe even black you know promotes
this pawn i will have to give up my
queen for his queen and then he has
another pawn then he's going to beat me
but if you know the theory behind this
position and it's very very simple
then you will never have to worry about
this again and you will only need a few
seconds on the clock
to win this game uh doesn't matter where
you're playing it so the point is uh
that
black has a c black has a b pawn and
that's important
so the a pawn is too far away for black
the defender
we have to eliminate the a pawn and then
the game is winning it doesn't matter
where the the the b pawn is if it's our
move so here uh gary played the queen to
uh queen to uh not went to e5 he played
queen to d4 with the idea of just
you know check and picking up the pawn
or just picking up the pawn with
check here we have b2 and now uh
queen to a for with check first we have
to push the black king in front of the
pawn
king to b1 and now king captures an a7
and this is all
very standard stuff so nothing out of
the ordinary happening here
uh the point is you now uh black only
needs one move so king c1 and then he
can promote his pawn to a queen
but it doesn't matter because it's a b
pawn that's never happening and i'm
going to show you why
king the c1 so now ready to promote to a
pawn
queen to c5 with check now if black goes
here we just attack his pawn so black
needs to defend his pawn
and now while the king is in front of
his own pawn we use this one
tempo to get uh our king uh closer into
the game so
uh while you could play king to the five
gear we played queen to c4 first
uh we have king the a1 quinte for king
to b1 and now okay basically the same
idea the the king is in front of the
pawn now we bring the
king closer into the position king to c1
uh we have now of cour we have to force
the king back
in front of the pawn so queen c4 check
king b1 and now king the e4
king the a1 queen to a for check again
we don't allow any uh
you know uh queen promotions king b1 and
now
king to d3 and now black is an ultimate
swan
there is nothing for him to do there's
only one move that's king to c1
and now queen to c2 will be checkmate
so this is what i wanted to show you
guys that uh from this position
uh it's only important that you you know
in a fraction of a second that you
understand that you have to
you you need to pick up the a7 pawn and
then the b pawn it doesn't matter where
it is doesn't matter where the black
king is if it's your move uh you will be
able to
to win this game uh and it goes the same
for example i will show you this
position i just show you the difference
let me just uh
uh load this all right uh
so it's a pretty much uh the same but
it's not
uh because here it's not a b pawn it's
an a pawn and here it's a problem here
you can't win this the problem is
after you start checking the the black
king for example king b1
we're going to deliver queen f2 checking
b2 queen e2 checking b1 queen d1 check
king b2
and i'll deliver all sorts of checks
there's no way for you to push the black
king in the corner or rather there is
you can play king b1 queen to b
for check now black will play king to c2
queen a3
attack the pawn king to b1 queen b3
check and yes now you
you can push the king in the corner but
after king to a1
uh you don't have uh this move with your
king because if you play this it's tail
mate the black king has no moves there
is no
uh you know uh something here to the
left
where the king can go to uh so that's
why
it would be a draw and it's very similar
if it's
uh if it's a c pawn it doesn't have to
be an a pawn
so you have to remember that if it's an
a pawn a c pawn an f pawn or an
h pawn then you will not be able to win
this position with white
uh you know regard okay maybe there are
there are definitely some positions
where i guess it's possible to
fix the position but usually not and if
it's uh
all right let's use the green one if
it's a bd e
or g pawn then you are winning it no
no problem because the black king will
be able to
uh have additional squares for you to
use to move your king closer to it
and here it's a draw it's uh the the
nicest draw possible because here after
queen to c6 for example queen b2 you're
gonna
start delivering checks of course uh you
want to get the black king in front of
the pawn so you can start pushing your
king in
let's say king get three we're gonna go
queen to d3 with
czecho after the pawn king defends it
now we're gonna pin it now
the black king has to play something
king b1 queen to b4
you're gonna play quick kink to a1
threaten to bring the queen into the
game
check king to b1 uh sorry uh for example
queen a3 check
king to b1 and now after this check uh
now white will think all right finally
you get
in front of the pawn and then i start
bringing my king into the game the
problem is king the a1
and you are never winning this because
now once you capture the c2 pawn it's
again
stalemate there are no squares for the
black king
so that's what you have to remember uh
like when this position
okay sorry about that um for some reason
that happens from time to time
uh if it's uh if it's a b pawn then it's
of course completely winning uh like i
said
uh b point b point d point e uh b one d
one e pawn and g pawn are completely
winning and of course these pawns are
not winning
so if you remember that then you don't
uh have to worry about any position
any situation on the clock you know that
okay this pawn is too far away i can
easily snap that pawn it's not a problem
there are many ways to do that
and then it regardless of where this
pawn is i'm going to be able to win the
end game and if you know that
then you know you will not have problems
uh
uh ever i even played um i
i even played a classical game against
the candidate master i think it was some
ten years ago i don't know uh and i uh
we had
we had this position and he had the c
pawn and
he was uh uh he had the queen and i had
the c pawn and he was
weirded out by why i was playing this he
was like i mean
why am i not resigning why are you even
playing this and i was like
where are you playing this i mean why
are you playing this it's a draw
and then uh after uh you know uh
he realized that there was no way to win
this game that it's uh
it's just a draw then he was like how
did i not know this
i mean he knew theory obviously he he
did study some in games but he did not
know
that the c pawn was also drawn so maybe
you can also use this in your own games
but yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh
yes a weird board again uh i i would
like to thank maxwell t cast leone tony
moa guitar joffrey waldron
uh rocket vishnu and richard black for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing with the coverage of the
prestigious mr dodgy invitational 2.0
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day